hey guys it is Monday my name is Jeff
I'm Dan and I hope you're ready for some
news because that's what we're gonna do
for next three minutes if I could make
an N with my fingers if your trips to
the toilet don't feature enough shotgun
blasts to the heads of Hell spawn
Bethesda have revealed when Doom is
coming to switch doom will make it to
the boo on Nintendo's hybrid console on
November 10 the switch port not only
includes the full single-player campaign
but also arcade mode multiplayer and all
previously released DLC if shooting
monsters with guns on your Nintendo box
isn't your speed you can shoot monsters
with arrows the week after when Skyrim
release is on switch on November 17th
you'll be able to stealth watch your way
through the entire campaign and all the
expansions there's also amiibo support
and motion control support but those of
you who want to flail around wildly the
conversation over PlayStation 4 and Xbox
one cross-play has heated up again with
the news that a dev has revealed a game
with intended cross play between PC
switch and Xbox one but not passport
before we start we need you guys to
suggest a good name for the cross play
situation so please suggest down below
cuz I say cross play situation cross
play drama we need with one developer
black riddles announced that its third
person shooter crazy justice will offer
cross play between the three consoles
but not ps4 there's a caveat though
crazy justice is currently seeking funds
on the crowdfunding site fig and is
currently at 95% of its 30 grand total
Sony has an aloud cross play with Xbox
one or any other platform as yet while
Microsoft have been pushing for the
feature pretty hard since e3 most
recently cross-platform play between the
consoles was accidentally enabled in
fortnight crazy justice is due out in
2018 on Xbox one switch PC and ps4 The
Witcher 3 developers that approached red
has been hit with some criticism lately
over some not so complimentary accounts
from ex employees and the studio has
released a statement regarding those
accounts Glassdoor is a site used to
review companies and supervisors and a
number of anonymous reviews have called
out the studio for various negative
workplace conditions including low pay
and long hours to the point where soda
products have released a statement in an
open letter on Twitter co-founder masa
Nowitzki and studio head Adam Podolski
explained
the company's culture saying they now
employ almost 400 people and while
people do leave this shouldn't concern
fans that any departures will jeopardize
the current projects they added that
their approach to making games is not
for everyone as they always seek to
quote reinvent the wheel
in regards to the hugely anticipated
cyberpunk 2077 the studio said the game
is progressing as planned but they are
taking their time you can check out the
full letter in our story on guess what
let's talk about this sure so lots of
big studios get this kind of publicity
rock stars a big one got it yeah that's
the big one that I can remember I mean
obviously the games industry there are a
lot of things that are a little murky in
workplace practices like crunch time and
it looks like that's been highlighted
from some ex-employees it is worth
noting that probably every company is
gonna have X employees who were like it
was the best place ever and those
reviews have started to roll in on
Glassdoor - oh come on then now it's a
lot of really positive responses because
instead of project have what light to it
right which kind of leads me to wonder
why they would bring light to it because
surely every company is gonna be
receiving some negative well I guess
they just want to get out ahead of it
and be like you know because there is
like you said there is kind of that idea
that video game development is awful and
you know some studios treat their
workers very badly I guess that a
probably wanted to get out ahead of that
and be like hey it's maybe not as bad as
all that although it was really
interesting that in the statement that
they released to get ahead of it they
didn't reference any of the specific
points that were made by ex employees
about long hours or low pay
it's just a job man making anything is
hard and especially with it's still
baffling to me the videogame somehow go
from an idea to being finished I don't
know how that how it happens it's some
sort of magic oh they do otherwise you
wouldn't have a job that's everything we
have for you today do let me know if you
enjoyed me wearing a white t-shirt
instead of my usual black or blues
jessica is wearing her I always wanted
one of three shirts but we'll be here
tomorrow and Wednesday but not Thursday
and Friday you guys are gonna have some
special hosts Thursday and Friday
because we're not gonna be here we're
having some days off but this is going
on for too long but
hey guys it is Monday my name is Josh
I'm Dan